the truth is about to come out and a lot
of Wellness influencers are gonna be
[Music]
mad hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome
back to my channel let's ruffle some
misinformed Wellness influencers
feathers so there is no shortage of Miss
and disinformation on social media right
now largely perpetuated by content
creators with huge platforms and zero
education or training in the field so I
thought we would play a little game
called let's make Wellness influencers
who are profiting off of pseudo science
super duper mad by breaking down the
science also don't forget to hit up my
description I've got a free Hunger
crushing combo ebook with lots of great
ideas for building balanced meals and
snacks and also please subscribe if you
have not already there is a lot more
where this came from okay folks
controversial claim not number one
drinking diet coke causes cancer an
ingredient found in drinks like Diet
Coke could have the potential to be
cancerous according to
scientists still don't love it so
recently the ho came out with a
recategorization of aspartame as a
carcinogen which the media interpreted
as Diet Coke causing cancer but this
feels to understand what the data and
classification system actually mean so
Tobacco For example is a group one
carcinogen which means that it's
carcinog to humans similar to alcohol
and asbestos red meat appears in group
2A along with air pollution and shift
work which means that it's probably
carcinus and yes I said shift work and
then aspartame falls into group 2B AKA
possibly carcinogenic to humans in case
you're wondering what else is classified
in group 2B like aspartame consider
things like aloe vera pickled vegetables
progesterone only contraceptives and
electromagnetic fields which your cell
phones emit around you all day now in
order for aspartam to meet the criteria
for 2B there has to be limited evidence
of Cancer Association in humans and
insufficient experimental evidence in
animals or if there's no human evidence
at all there has to be enough evidence
that there is a mechanism in animals
that could potentially apply to humans
in other words it is far from causation
what makes this classification even more
confusing and some ways kind of useless
is that it just tells you about the
strength of the evidence not how risky
it is in real life or how much of the
substance would be needed to actually
cause harm all of these substances are
basically just lumped into one category
as if spending your entire life
breathing an ashal is the same as having
an occasional can of Diet Coke we may
see updated recommendations in the
future but right now the FDA has
suggested that a daily intake of 50 Mig
per kilogram of body weight or like 19
cans of diet coca day would be under the
safe amount so friends the dose makes
the poison I don't personally drink diet
coke as you can see it's not my vibe but
I think you should treat aspartame like
sugar and enjoy it in moderation it's
not a health food but it's probably not
going to be the primary reason for
anyone's decline moving on to a cookie
but a goodie a six-pack is a healthy
goal for all women okay I'm going to
tell you guys how I got abs um here are
my credentials
um I feel like a lot of people over
complicate it and it's really very
simple this one will definitely make the
fitness influencer girlies mad because
spoiler alert it's not and here's the
thing some women naturally have more
visible abs without having to put
themselves through an outrageously
restrictive diet or ere ex exercising
protocol and hormonally they may appear
completely healthy but the vast majority
of us women are just not meant to be
that lean to see visible abde definition
like a tight sixpack most women need to
get down to 14 to 20% body fat and yet
most of us need around 26 to 28% body
fat to regulate our cycle reproductive
hormones and support natural fertility
again bodies come in all different
shapes and sizes and there are a lot of
women who can maintain low body fat
percentages have a six-pack and still
get a period ovulate and get pregnant
but typically the behaviors taken to get
said six-pack AKA extreme chloric
restriction OV exercising or both with
or without a low body fat percentage are
also huge risk factors for an ovulation
a menorrhea and hormonal irregularities
so despite what social media may make
you believe a six-pack should not be the
goal this one's really going to push
some people's buttons but if it's part
of the dirty dozen you absolutely must
biorganic ewg just released their 2023
list of the dirty dozen in Clean 15 if
Bob's talking about it you know I'm
going to have something to say so the
dirty dozen is a list that's released
annually by the egw or the environmental
working group where they list the fruits
and vegetables with the greatest
pesticide residues if you haven't heard
of the ewg lucky you but in short they
Market themselves as being these
unbiased truth Crusaders going
head-to-head with big food the FDA and
USDA and other major health authorities
basically they rank food products based
on how clean they are loudly opposing
any conventionally grown or GMO crops
and while they are super vague about
their sponsors and donors they do list a
number of organic food brands and clean
Beauty Brands which many claim may
affect how these brands are ranked
without proper disclosure transparency
issues aside I am personally a lot more
concerned with some of their dubious
anti-science board members and the fact
that they have published blatant
disinformation incling including a 2004
article linking vaccines to autism that
right there should be a big red FL so
yeah I've never personally been a fan so
the way they come up with their dirty
dozen list is by looking at the
pesticide data program which samples
more than 10,000 food samples for
pesticide residues their findings
actually remind us how safe our food
actually is seeing as over 99% of
samples tested had residues below the
tolerances set by the EPA and 42% had no
detectable pesticide residues at all in
fact the residues here are so low that
we would reach toxicity levels from the
fruit or vegetable themselves before we
would reach toxicity levels from the
pesticides on them the alliance for food
and farming developed a calculator to
show you how many servings of a dirty
dozen fruit or veg you would actually
need to eat in one day to reach beyond
the no adverse effects level and here
are the results you'd have to eat almost
2,000 peaches over 2300 nectarines
nearly 75 500 servings of kale 340
apples or almost 7500 servings of celery
you would be sh your pants all day for
days if you ate this not because of the
pesticides but because of the fodmaps
and fiber so obviously folks the dose
makes the poison now the other issue
with the dirty dozen is similar to the
issue on how carcinogens like aspartame
are classified it doesn't incorporate
risk assessment into the calculations
all of the pesticides are weighted
equally and we don't factor in the
levels deemed acceptable by the EPA in
other words the list is based solely on
residue count not what the chemical is
what concentration it is in that food
and how those levels compare to the
epa's tolerance levels for specific
chemicals they also never mentioned the
fact that organic foods contain
pesticides too which may or may not be
safer than synthetic like anyone
remember the natural organic pesticide
rotenone we thought that was super safe
because it was all natural but it ended
up attacking the mitochondria and
causing Parkinson's disease in rats my
point here is not that organic foods are
also bad it's that assuming you're not
eating thousands of peaches every single
day conventional produce is absolutely
safe and fear-mongering wellness
information like The Dirty Dozen does
actual harm here one study found that
fearmongering pesticide messaging
resulted in lowincome families who
couldn't afford organic produce to
purchase less produce altogether we
don't need to further the health
disparities in this country with
misinformation like this so organic
conventional buy whatever you can afford
and just like wash it well and speaking
of produce if you don't eat vegetables
just drink ag1 here is my everyday
pickme up and breakfast that has really
helped my gut health and floating oh boy
this one's going to be spicy so I jve
deep into the claims and facts in my
greens powder video right here but in
short I don't see anything wrong with
greens powders and some may be better
than others but at least as they appear
on the market today they will not
replace fed vegetables are not just like
a combination of micronutrients they're
one of the best sources of dietary fiber
and it's fiber more than almost anything
that most North Americans are not
getting enough of that should be the
focus of eating your green stuff not the
4 67% of your vitamin see in ag1 that
you're just going to pee out anyway
interestingly a lot of the influencers
are promoting Brands like ag1 and Bloom
greens as being great for bloating but
if you legitimately suffer from bloating
and therefore have a sensitive gut a lot
of the ingredients in these powders are
just going to make things worse things
like inulin fiber chory root and
fructooligosaccharides just to name a
few now there's a lot of great stuff in
these things too don't get me wrong but
since these beneficial ingredients are
often and bundled in these huge
proprietary Blends we actually have zero
clue of how much you're actually getting
most of the functional ingredients
listed on labels have clinical doses of
1 to 10 G each and since each scoop of
powder is generally in the 10 to 15 G
range it is highly unlikely that you're
getting clinically relevant doses of
most if not all of those ingredients you
could also hypothetically be getting
dangerously high amounts of some of
these ingredients for you so just
something to keep in mind if if you want
to know exactly what you're taking
bottom line I don't think that there's
anything wrong with taking greens
powders and some are better than others
but think of them as like a powdered
multivitamin with flavor not a
replacement for actual fiber rich veg
and finally oats are toxic and bad for
your blood sugars I've done a couple
episodes now where oatmeals come up and
I think people are starting to realize
it's not a good option it's not a good
option at all not just because of the
actual oats but the glyphosate the
oatmeal heat has been Fierce this year
namely thanks to a lot of carnivore or
paleo influencers doing the podcast
circuit but let's set a few things
straight here one oats are not bad for
your blood sugars like the carnivore
Clan insists how do I know this oh hi
there hugan analysis and systematic
review of the literature that found that
oats were beneficial for blood glucose
control oats actually significantly
reduced A1C fasting glucose total
cholesterol LDL cholesterol acute
proprial glucose and Insulin responses
now the type of Oats will matter when it
comes to satiety and how long they'll
hold you so instant oats will cause the
greatest Spike and fall while steel cut
oats will maintain blood glucose levels
longer as will what you serve with it
adding protein and fat effectively
lowers the blood sugar curve and this is
all what I recommend anyways so try
adding nuts seeds high fiber berries
hemp Parts flax protein powder and milk
to your o help stabilize blood sugars
and improve satiety next let's talk
about glyphosate so to start all this
hysteria around glyphosate is based on
Independent opinions by the ewg or
environmental working group which as
we've established is pretty well
understood to be a dubious Source in the
science Community but let's put their
findings into some context here the
epa's tolerable limit for glyphosate is
30 Perth per million the ewg found that
the worst oat of Fender contained up to
2800 ppb AKA 2.8 parts per million based
on the official EPA standards you would
have to consume over 10 servings of
conventionally grown oats a day to reach
that amount please do not do that now of
course the ewg claims the limits should
be much lower which is a totally fair
belief but just like their funding
sources they're not super transparent
about what these opinions for benchmarks
are based on that said but if you're
still concerned because you or your kids
eat a lot of oatmeal like mine do then
consider organic or stretch your portion
by adding in all of those blood sugar
regulating ingredients that I just
shared you definitely should not give up
your oats when I make oats for myself
and my kids I typically do like 2/3 oats
1/3 hemp Parts a ripe banana a scoop of
peanut butter a little bit of butter
protein Rich milk high fiber berries and
usually some sprinkles and chocolate
chips on top obviously and trust me I am
full for a good while so obviously there
are a lot more misinformed Wellness
influencer claims to unpack here so
please leave me a comment below with
whatever you want me to discuss in more
detail and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
bye